Welcome back.
We are now on problem
number 12, which
I will do in magenta.
All right.
If 2x is less than y, which
is less than 0-- huh.
So both of these are negative,
and 2x is more negative.
All right.
Which of the following
is greater?
So they give us a bunch
of choices.
So let's see.
Choice A is minus 2x.
Choice B is minus 2x plus y.
Choice C is 2x.
Choice D is 0.
And choice E is minus y.
OK.
So the interesting thing that
should immediately jump out at
you is that both 2x and
y are negative, right?
Because they're all
less than 0.
And 2x is even more
negative than y.
Right?
If I were to draw a number line,
if this is the number
line-- we might be instructed
to even show it.
This is 0.
This is y.
2x would be some place
over here.
We don't know exactly where.
This could be 0, this
could be-- I
could pick random numbers.
This could be negative 1.
And then this could
be negative 2.
Right?
These are just random numbers.
And actually, that might
be the best way
of doing this problem.
We could reason through it,
and actually, I will.
But the easiest thing is, well,
let me just take these
numbers that satisfy this
inequality and see what
happens with them, right?
And that probably is
the fastest way.
So in our case, what's
minus 2x?
So if 2x is minus 2, that would
be minus times minus 2.
Because 2x is minus 2.
So that equals plus 2.
What's 2x plus y?
So 2x is minus 2, plus
y is minus 1.
So it becomes a minus 3.
So this becomes minus minus 2
minus 1, so that's minus 3,
but then you have a minus
outside so it's plus 3.
So we can immediately
say that this is not
the greatest, right?
Because we already found
one that is greater.
2x would be just minus 2.
We said that. soon.
2x is minus 2.
0 is 0.
Minus y in our example
would be 1.
In all of these situations, this
is the largest. And you
could try it with any set of
numbers that satisfy this.
We could have called this--
instead of saying this is 2x,
we could have called
this z and done it.
But without doing the number
line, and without picking
numbers, you could have
also reasoned.
You could have said, 2x is
more negative than y.
So if you put a negative in
front of 2x, it's going to be
more positive.
Right?
Because a negative times a
negative is a positive.
So it'll become a
more positive.
So first of all, this number
will be a negative number, so
that's not right.
This number will be positive,
so 0 can't be the answer.
And then you say, well,
what's bigger?
Minus y or minus 2x?
Well, minus 2x is more negative,
so minus-- or sorry.
2x is more negative, so minus
2x will be more positive.
So you know it's not
going to be this.
So then you're picking
between these two.
And then you have to say, well,
what's more negative?
2x or 2x plus y?
Well, 2x plus y is going to
be a more negative number,
because both of these are
negative numbers.
So when you add them, you're
going to get something even
more negative than
either of them.
Then we take the negative of
that, you get a larger
positive number.
That last explanation might
have been confusing.
And really, the easiest way is
just pick some numbers that
satisfy this inequality.
And then substitute, and then
you have your answer.
All right.
Number 13, which I'll do
in this pale yellow.
Carlos delivered n packages
on Monday.
So Monday, n.
4 times as many packages on
Tuesday as on Monday.
So on Tuesday, he did 4 times
as many, so that's 4n.
And 3 more-- not 3 times, 3
more-- packages on Wednesday
than Monday.
So Wednesday, 3 more packages
on Wednesday than Monday.
So this is n plus 3, 3
more than on Monday.
What is the average number of
packages he delivered per day
over the three days?
So what's the average of
these three numbers?
So let's see.
We sum them up.
n plus 4n plus n plus 3, and
we divide by 3, because
there's three days.
n plus 4n is 5n, plus
3 is 6n. you
So it's 6n plus 3 over 3.
Divide all the terms by 3,
that equals 2n plus 1.
And we are done.
That was number 13,
which was C.
Number 14.
This looks exciting.
a plus b to the 1/2 is equal to
a minus b to the minus 1/2.
Which of the following
must be true?
And they say, b is equal to 0.
That's choice A.
They say a plus b
is equal to 1.
a minus b is equal to 1.
a squared plus b squared
is equal to 1.
a squared minus b squared
Well, what I want to do is, I
just want to write this in a
form that makes more
sense to me.
So this is essentially saying
the square root of a plus b is
equal to 1 over the square
root of a minus b.
Right?
Negative 1/2.
So let's multiply both sides
of this equation times the
square root of a minus b.
This side will just
cancel out, right?
And you're just left with 1.
This is the same thing as the
square root of a minus b
times a plus b.
Right?
And then on the right-hand
side, we're
just left with a 1.
And what's a minus
b times a plus b?
So this is the square root of
a squared minus b squared is
equal to 1.
We could square both
sides, right?
So if we square both sides, so
we take both to the second
power, what are we left with?
This radical sign goes away, so
we're left with a squared
minus b squared is equal to 1.
And that is choice E.
Let's see.
Do I have time to do
the next problem?
It looks complicated.
So let me wait to do the next
problem in the next video.
See